welcome thank you very much for
talk we hope
[Music]
today on a stage I'm Marcus
and that's fine hi we're working for
mobility I'm working for mobility flow
and it's working for in of X and as
we've been introduced we're going to
talk a bit about personalization we're
gonna start with a more a general
introduction who are we why are we here
why do we wanted to give a talk where
for you at PI data digging into a
personalization use cases we have at
mobility a digging even further and like
showing you one example of a person
ization approach which is predicting a
car buying intent of our users and then
we go more to the technical side that's
actually going to be presented by a
Florian Python for big data processing
so how do we approach this on our side
using Python and then optimizing
performance all right just as an
introduction for those of you who don't
know mobility is a German website where
you can bike hives we have new cars and
used cars car dealers so this is the
general company were working for we're
all part of eBay tags so mobility
belongs to eBay tech were also a client
side for example belongs to actually
quite broad also in other countries
Gumtree ki GG and marktplatz to say
about about mobility it's the biggest
car market online in germany we have
around 13.5 million unique users per
month and around 1.6 million vehicles on
our site every day we split between two
locations in Berlin one is the most of
us are like situated in close to vans
days called Callen and then we have
another headquarter in Felix time
talking about data so just that you have
a rough estimate what how data looks for
us we have around 50 million search
events per day 40 million individual
view events or like people looking at
event listings to work house 1 million
piking event spiking forces watching
other websites call wish listing so you
put something on your wish wish list
because it's Kairos piking was a nicer
name
1.5 1.6 million listings and around
800,000 times they any of those these
things are changed by our dealers and a
lot of like contacts for dealers so this
is what we have to deal with pretty much
on an everyday basis if I say we it's
actually not just the two of us there
are a number of people here so this is
even just a sub fraction of all the
people that work together with us it's a
very nice team of data scientists data
engineers we have back-end developers
front-end developers we have people
working in data products it's a very
very nice mission make sure we actually
don't always dress like that that was
for a Christmas party and we had a game
of throne themed presentation so that
was how this came into being yeah yeah
short word about innovative Ian's IT
project house we have been supporting a
mobile er in this combined endeavor for
more than three years and we are still
up there like cool data products with
them and we have offices in Castle
Cologne unique Watson Hamburg and
Stuttgart and besides data science and
data engineering we also do operations
and app development and trainings all
right so why do we want to talk about
personalization I like to use this
example it's 14 Germans called the tanta
M Aladdin English translation would be
probably aunt Emma's little store or
something like this so if you go to any
of those stores what you usually see is
a lot of products so you get inspiration
of what you want to buy and you might
even get engaged by some things you
maybe didn't expect it to find but are
very interesting and you might even want
to come back just for exactly that
this is Aunt Emma she's really nice aunt
and she's always very friendly even to
customers that never been to her store
and of course first time she you come in
she probably doesn't know your name you
never been there she's just she's gonna
treat you as a random person well
actually you liked hung on Emma store so
therefore you're coming back it's a nice
store why not coming back and you're
coming back and back
she remembers you maybe already at the
second time and she's like I you've been
here you bought I don't know beans
whatever milk and maybe even become a
regular so she's gonna like greet you
you're coming into a store every day and
of course
just imagine Emma would feed you every
day the same way she did the first day
for me that would be very I would be
very unhappy about this because yes I'm
unique I'm me so therefore if I come
back to town Aunt Emma store I want to
be treated as me I wanted to be treated
in a personalized way and that's exactly
what personalization does on the
Internet
that's that something like this works
has been shown a number of times so I
guess you all know the Facebook newsfeed
which is your newsfeed you're not seeing
like the newsfeed of everyone else
Pinterest gives you discovery of
pictures you might be interested in
Spotify is giving very personalized
music recommendation and very similar is
Netflix why do people do that well as I
said first it drives user experience
like we all feel treated as who we are
individually and also engages users to
your website how do we do that at
mobility when a user interacts with our
website we track those events and store
them in a Hadoop ecosystem and then we
have in general two approaches to
personalization one we call a preference
so if a user comes to our website we are
thinking about what are your car
preferences and we're making anonymize
profiles all of this we assemble them
over multiple days and before example
use them to give your recommendations
which are very specific review the our
other approach to to personalization is
what we call user interactions or also
user intense so you're interacting with
our website on a specific time of day
you having a specific idea again we
assemble this over a number of days and
then we use it for example for
segmentation or what I always call user
intent modeling as if for example we're
going to go this route just to tell you
a bit about this so this is the
user preferences let's for example say
that user is into used cars not used car
not new cars he's split between two
German makes BMW and Audi and then even
we drill down deeper saying okay what
are the individual models you're into
what's your radius of search what's the
area you would actually drive to a
dealer to find a car what's the
preferred price range you're looking for
and what's your mileage we define those
based on different interactions because
different interactions where the website
is show how much you're carrying for
specific cars would you made a view did
you put it on your wish list did you
made a contact to that we have a certain
a modeling approach for uncertainty I'm
not going to go too much into details
actually Florian and all our colleague
Anna shot this last year on PI data it's
been recorded so if you're interested in
recommendation it's worth checking out I
just roughly tell you what we do we use
a Bayesian approach to model uncertainty
might be that you've just been here the
first time and we still want to give
give you some recommendations right so
therefore we use the Bayesian approach
and an idea of a prior which we generate
over all the users we have on a website
and when you come initially to our
website you you're treated as that prior
you interact more and more and more you
generate more went with our website and
therefore at some point you as you and
as treated as such and then this is how
our recommendation engine works it's
been recently updated to a deep
recommendation engine using tenza flow
also that one has been presented at the
buzzword by our colleague ego Mazar
again worth checking out so how does it
work in general we have an idea of the
rough feature space we have of course
we're representing cars as numbers we
have a collaborative information
approach that's the the classical people
who search for this also search for that
this kind of thing we have the user
preferences I told you before and we put
this all through our recommendation
engine and then we rate in all of our
listings
you feel for that individual user and
give recommendations based on that
that's one of the approaches that's this
point I went here let's go to the other
side user intent so that you have an
idea I give you some examples what that
mean let's assume that guy here he
actually buys the car his first car ever
he has no idea what should a car cost
what actually kind of cried do I need so
the intent here is you need a lot of
information and you need guidance that's
a very specific thing let's let's go for
her she's a total expert knows
everything about cars she wants to have
the perfect deal in the fastest way
going to the website spent two days and
like had the new car running that guy he
really loves cars but he actually
doesn't buy the car so often maybe other
people buy them for him I don't know so
he bros for mostly expensive cars but
actually he doesn't want to go to a
dealer in the end and then there's this
guy it's an actual car dealer he uses
our website to find out about his the
people that also sell cars what is their
price range what kind of Christ would
they have in the market right now what
should how much should he does he get
for individual cars so if you look at
those four people actually their intents
are very different and like making one
website which is giving you the perfect
experience for all of them is really
high so the idea is personalizing put
make differences between those people to
understand what's your intent we always
go for something we call a car buying
journey that's very different things
also let's let's for us actually it's
quite simple it's based on data so it's
a data a car buying journey that are
individual events I told you about them
it's like making contacts your Park a
car you make a view you make searches
and this is over a timeline so here are
a lot of interactions there's less maybe
had some like days off
here's more this is the kind of data we
look at and we were interested how does
that look like so we got around 4,000
buyers we had on our website and said
okay let's look at their individual car
buying data car buying journeys we got
some controls randomly picked
users and we assembled around 75 million
interactions for those users and I'm
first going to give you a bit of like
what does the data look like what could
we learn from looking at those events
this here are some graphs I'm gonna
explain them so it's not too hard
0 on the y axis always means this is the
first time we ever saw you and one is
like this is the last day you have been
on our website and on the y-axis here
you have different events for example
make a contact the darker line is our
buyer group and the lighter line is or
control group so in this case what you
see is like the chance of making a
contact is increasing to the end well
that's probably what you all get because
car buying takes quite a lot of time so
usually like initially you're more into
like the information gathering stage and
in the end you want to make a contact to
your dealer because you actually want to
get your car running right so it
increases quite a lot for buyers it also
increases for control but not as
dramatically if you go for the piking
piking was much more flat and actually
increased much more for the control
group interesting example is the amount
of cars you're actually viewing let's
taste pretty much the same over your
whole car journey so you're constantly
generating the same amount of Christ
you're looking at and searches are
actually going down so the amount of
different searches you're doing is is
reduced because in the end it's more
like you already have all the car
interesting you just want to make
comparison look at them individually
that was something interesting for me
the amount of duplicated views so how
often do you look at a car you've
already seen I don't know whoever did
buy a car online but that's actually
something I also did that in the end I
always just like open all the same cars
again and look at them again because you
really want to make sure so this is this
kind of behavior we see that our buyers
like top form like around 30% of
duplicate car is to always half of the
listings you see are you actually seen
already and that's also true with the
control group but not as dramatic and
then the question I found interesting
when do people actually interact with a
car they're gonna buy in the end
and what you see is that around like
7080 percent in your college journey
this is where you interact the most with
a car you bought in the end and in the
end it goes down again a best
explanation for this is that people just
before they buy a car I like getting a
bit like maybe I get the wrong one so we
like starting a more broader search
again but then often coming back to the
car you already made the decision for
this kind of analysis we're very
promising to us so we said like maybe we
can use these kind of things in a
machine learning approach to predict
that you want to buy a car today that
this is so this is exactly what we
wanted to do predict that what can you
do with it it's for a personalization
approach because when you want to buy a
car what's really important for you is
that you can make comparisons between
cars and you can make a contact very
easily so a nice thing would be to
highlight the dealer context and more
clearly and also provide you with car
buying assistance in case for example
you need a financing or whatever it's
which is not that unusual obviously if
you buy a car so we put that into a
machine learning approach and that is
how it looked like we generated number
of features you have your buying dates
we took the last 30 days in your journey
and we generated the features the
individual events you had the
distribution of those events between
each other how many days you have been
active over the last 30 days and some
additional features which were the
amount of views where the searches that
actually came out very predictive in one
of on Alice's and the amount of
duplicated views which I showed you
before we didn't just do this over the
30 days but we actually also defined
windows so in this example it's like
okay the last three days of your
interaction the week before and the 20
days before and then we even be computed
ratios between those because this is
like your what what's changed right we
already see that's quite a number of
parameters in that model so how did we
went forward and we used a logistic
regression approach for this one and
given that the number of features is so
big actually we needed a feature
selection to prevent overfitting so we
started from different sub J as
subsections or selections of those
features
and added or subtracted automatically
based on a kikah information criterion
and then coming up with different models
we even went one step forward I told you
that there were windows that we had
individual features so we also optimized
that that's how that looks like we
define different windows and tried all
of them ours put that into an
optimization what came out as the best
was looking at your last day of
interaction looking at the week before
and looking at the three weeks before
that and you put this all into a machine
learning model and you predict you do a
cross we did a cross-validation 15-fold
and a 70/30 train test split and that's
the best model that came out of that so
we reach an accuracy of predicting that
you're gonna buy the car today or making
this this final call today by 70% with
the sensitivity of around 68% and a
specificity of 76% that was really nice
we said like oh how cool so like but
this is today maybe we can also predict
it to do this tomorrow or you do it in a
week or in two well what happened is
yeah we were directly declining so the
more you go into the future the highly
this product damn humans we're actually
changing your minds but it's definitely
a very interesting problem and we're
still on this so if anyone here in the
audience knows about this and they are
very curious about learning more how you
can actually pretty progress more into
the future with this so like it's not
it's not bad but you can definitely see
that it's declining so I told you about
the big data pride and I'm gonna hand
over to Florian because we're tight 8's
who's gonna tell you something about
Python yes so we've heard about the many
interesting use cases of some of the
interesting use cases that are at mobile
oh of course there are many others and
yeah since we're on the PI data of
course you're interested to see and to
hear how tight and what kind of role
does it play because python is a
language you all know you have to global
interpreter lock and a lot of things
happen in memory so the language itself
is not really tailored for big data but
of course yeah you can do big data with
it and we make a lot of use of the
Hadoop ecosystem together with
with pipe so when I arrived like like
two and a half year ago I started on the
working on the on the data team at
mobile and at that time a lot of high
force use so who knows - you just too
short okay
many people know hive so it's really it
has been and still is kind of the
workhorse for doing big data it's an
Apache project it's it's built on top of
Hadoop it's basically an SQL engine and
it's translating the SQL - to MapReduce
and it's really good at this it's over
the years it's became really robust it's
mature it's really the workhorse for it
and it has the disadvantage though that
it's quite slow and truly not
interactive and if you are a data
scientist if you want to come up with
cool models you of course want something
that is fast and you want to iterate and
try out new things so it's not really
the the cool thing but at that time it
was yeah to go to things so the the user
preferences that we heard about in the
first part of the talk and user
segmentation we're built with this
because of course we are pragmatic you
you use what you have and we were using
the PI hive library so if you wanna use
hive I can really recommend the PI high
fly berry by Dropbox it nowadays also
has the PI 3 support and so the question
is how did we actually use it so I said
it's an SQL engine but of course we have
seen we used some nice models and you
cannot really do cool machine learning
models only based on SQL and you do this
by using user-defined functions so
what's the user defined function or user
defined aggregation function so
basically you always need this when the
native function of hive or for spark or
whatever aren't enough if you cannot
express what you want to do as a
composition of your native functions
and then you can define your own
function you should be aware that those
user-defined functions most of the time
are much much slower than the native
ones so use them only when you really
have to and yeah they work on on groups
or sets of columns and group data so you
can imagine that's like if you do your
group by and you say okay on those two
columns I want to do some operation and
get the result back so I mean most
people surely know pandas so just to to
get your over to pandas so to compare it
basically user defined functions you can
maybe separate in three kind of troops
you have like more like a transform like
and pandas that you do really vector
based on each of row aggregation this
would be an SQL a kind of prove I and
some aggregation functions so you start
off with a vector and you could only
single value or you can even be
completely flexible like the apply
function in pandas that you get a vector
in and you can completely decide if you
get a smaller large vector or whatever
out so with this we were we were using
things like this for for hive and but
then we realized okay yeah given the
disadvantages of slow and you had to
include you somehow in SQL we were
looking for alternatives and like two
years ago it was really hot spot was a
or still is a big thing but it really
was a lot of hype around it so we were
looking at spark and spark is a fast and
general processing engine for large data
I think all many of people know spark
it's written in Scala so of course this
is kind of the downside so you cannot
directly use it but of course there are
nowadays good Python API is for it so
Python is even declared like a
first-class citizen for accessing spark
and so together
it's called PI spark and yeah we were
looking into is it this and decided okay
that's the way for us to go we can
actually go and start my grey
a lot of our use cases from hive to
spark and yeah get than the many
benefits so to show you one so for
instance the user preferences that we
heard about so we did a migration and we
had a lot of benefits so first of all we
could dramatically reduce the lines of
code so we went from two thousand five
hundred lines of code to 1,700 and there
this also included new features so this
is actually would be a lower number if
if you would have stayed on the same
feature set then as I said before so we
were using kind of ginger to to do some
SQL queries and this is really not a
nice way but sparked and allowed us to
define queries in a much more
programmatic kind of way so it's much
much easier to define your queries also
we get rid of a lot of temporary tables
and this was also important there the
run time so the run time for this model
of course you don't want to have your
model run four to ten hours because you
want to include a new data as fast as
possible and we could reduce it by just
using spark to one to two hours so this
is yeah this interval is due to the fact
how the usage on the cluster is for me
actually one of the biggest gains was
that the the source code after the
migration was much easier to understand
so for new employees and new tree
members it was much easier to to look at
this bar code and see AHA that's
happening there compared to what we did
in hive so before I go a little bit more
into UDF's and the advantages and
disadvantages of it just to make sure
that everyone understands how a spark
actually works so on spark you have a
kind of separation into a driver program
this is where you are kind of working in
this is where you tribute a lab to but
your notebooks runs your ipython kernel
whatever and this process is
orchestrating the worker nodes so
they're the executors are running and
there is where
actually big data processing takes place
and so I said before so we were using
Python so what happens actually if you
call some some Titan user-defined
function so inside a spark worker what
but what Spock does is it's starting
python processes and the data for the
python process is then serialized send
over to the Python process there's
deserialized then your defined function
is applied
it's serialized again it sent over over
the the pipe and the spark worker is
deserializing it again and and there you
are
so you already by saying a lot of
serializing and deserializing going back
and forth you see that is surely it's a
large overhead and this actually makes
up like 8090 percent of the actual
processing is not happening in here and
then the Python Python module and you're
actually maybe machine learning model
but it's really happening in there this
going back and forth and this is not
only a problem that this paja has this
is actually a problem that a lot of
tools has whenever you go from like one
kind of library or one kind of world
like java virtual machine to c and
whatever back and forth you have this
for a lot of tools and actually this was
recognized as being a major problem so
the guy FS makini the guy who the
inventor of pandas said ok I'm gonna I'm
gonna do something about it and came up
with a the Apache Apache arrow library
and this is a really hot topic now so
there later is going to also be a talk
about this how you can use it to extend
pandas so with the help of Apache arrows
so this is really a important thing and
it basically so just a rough idea is
that it kind of defines an abstract
memory llao layout for your data and
whoever is using the same layout does
not need to do all these serialization
deserialization again to get the data
into the right structures so
luckily spark is using this in version
2.3 so if you're lucky enough that you
can use spock 2.3 and so if your cluster
is already updated by the operation guy
you can use it and then you have a
really nice way of defining your
user-defined functions you have this dis
pandas UDF decorator and here is just
some examples some cumulative
distribution function and you see that
you can define this function with the
help of a pandas series and you then
define okay here's my new column and you
just call this and basically what
happens in the background is that the
Java data is is then by using pandas
arrow copied over to the to the to the
Python process as a series and there's
no civilization deserialization again so
that's directly this pandas series you
can also do this much much the same way
with the same flexibility as pandas
apply so you can also easily define
functions on whole data frames and
decide yeah if you want to aggregate or
do whatever functions you do and this
gives you a lot of flexibility you can
also group by and do then something so
it's it's really really cool so use
definitely Python and spark 2.3 if you
have the chance and just to give you a
rough idea of what kind of performance
gains you would expect compared to the
old way old versions they see that for
the the CDF example you have more than
200 percent if 200 times it's it's
faster more than 200 times so the thing
is what is if you are not able to use
spark 2.3 because maybe your operation
team hasn't yet updated the the hive
clutter that is source park cluster or
your distribution like direct cloud
hartenberg hasn't yet done the proper
updates so this is something we had to
deal with and in the past because I mean
we've been doing the migration we had
been doing the migration like like one
and a half year ago we finished this so
we had to come around with another way
of defining really flexible UDF's and
letting the data scientists define their
function in with the help of pandas
because this is what what people like
and we came up with a nice solution with
the help of going from the data frames
back to the rdd's and using the map
partition and then some some decorators
that we define so that you also can use
pandas and it's a little bit more
efficient than the traditional way but
of course not as good as pandas udev is
fewer also stuck with an older version
of spark and you're interested then you
can look this up we wrote a little blog
post about it how you can actually use
it
so another important topic is if you now
have the flexibility of writing cool
user-defined functions where you apply
whole models then you kind of want to
use the power of pipe and the power of
piping really comes from the ecosystem
so meaning libraries like scikit-learn
pandas of course sai pie starts model
and so on and if you want to use this
you also want to make sure that you have
the right the right versions of those
libraries installed and this is quite
easy if you're doing just normal pipe
need use some virtual and or kondeh
environment and so on but with spark
it's a little bit more complicated you
either can tell your operation team so
please roll out those versions those
packages those libraries with those
versions on the whole cluster or you
give your data scientists like route
access to the different executors which
is never a good idea and of course you
also want to make sure that if there's
an upgrade happening on your cluster you
don't will all your don't want all your
applications to probably stop working
because they rely on an older version so
you want to keep this really tight to
the to the specific application so this
is also a technical challenge we had to
deal with and we come up with the I
think quite nice solution because
there's no official solution yet so
people at SPARC are working on this so
we came up with ideas so why not create
a local environment based on wheels and
upload those and why mint and HDFS
because every data scientist of course
is able to write in specific directories
on HDFS and then you can tell the driver
process so please distribute those files
with the help of add file in spark to
the local memory of the executors nodes
and if you then run your actual model or
whatever you want to do on this back
cluster then it's using those libraries
and this allows you to really flexible
per application define what libraries in
which versions you want and use so we
also have written that this down because
this is really technical in a nice blog
post to give you an overall idea how it
works
so normally you just start your your
productive spark shops with the help of
spark submit and what we now do is we
have called so called activate
environment Python file and what this
basically does is it's telling the spark
driver ok here is somewhere a virtual
environment that the data scientists
already created for you and it's reading
in those those libraries in the Indus if
ik person stare in the driver and this
is distributing this on the on the on
the spark executors and then the spark
executors so then the driver process
calls the actual program so this is kind
of free step and then the actual machine
learning model or whatever is called
this can then use the libraries you
defined here and this yeah works pretty
well and yeah for for like like one year
we're using this in production so it
works quite well but of course if there
is one day an official solution we would
rather also go for the peaceful solution
so to to summarize we've we've seen that
at eBay there are many many interesting
challenging use cases that all have a
high impact it's a really data driven
company we've heard a lot about the data
science parts in it what kind of models
we use also some data engineering expect
aspects we on the technical side we use
the PI data stack we're really keen on
data on Titan especially combined with
Hadoop and spark and if you are now
interested and say well cool it's
exactly the kind of use cases I want to
work on with the Python stack then you
are really welcome to talk to us our
booth we are also hiring so eBay is
hiring in Berlin and yeah I'm looking
forward to hear from you thanks a lot
and of course we're open for questions
progress
hi as I understand you have some kind of
recommend engine written in terms of
flow and some data processing in PI
spark so I wonder how do you integrate
those because I just wonder if you
integrate them somehow yeah so the
question was we have some things in in
PI spark for data transformations and so
on and other things like our
recommendation engine is tensorflow and
how do we combine all those so we use
Jenkins for a lot of things to define
the different work steps so I mean you
talked before we heard about air flow we
were also looking into air flow for
something like this but actually we yeah
we found out that for our needs Jenkins
was better because you can also define
your graph and what is happening there
and so on so there are certain chops
that do our data ingestion data
transformations and run some of the
models then as user defined functions
and save them back in HDFS so HDFS is
kind of our yeah kind of API sometimes
for so chops put stuff in new tables
create new petitions and then another
job comes and reads in the data again
and that's for instance the
recommendations or training the model so
actually when the model is trained and
the recommendations there of course they
need to happen real time and there it's
incompletely another service I mean you
train it from HDFS but then it's running
also on some kind of private cloud as a
micro service and the website is sending
rest requests to this micro service and
tensorflow serving is then your
answering and giving the replies with
with the recommendations
hi hi thank you for the great talk I
have a question regarding environments
you create on the executors yeah you
create those environments to use panda
to use Python libraries for machine
learning right yeah but how do you
manage to share the the results between
the executors because if you are
training a model I think you can't do
this you need you need to aggregate
somehow the results yes so I think is it
like like are like two topics so the
virtual environment or kind of the
virtual environment is not created on
the executed script on HDFS like a
single virtual environment and then with
the help of this boilerplate code that
we came up with this if I switch back
this activate environment then the add
file command of spark is used to
distribute it to the executors but only
in the in the local in memory so it's
only exists while the job are running
they get copies of the one virtual
environment which in HDFS so it's only
like like in memory and then the the
actual spark job I mean there of course
you have to see how it yeah how how you
partition your data to run your your
model if you if you have a model that
basically needs all the data at the same
time then of course you have a problem
because your data resides on one
executor and some of another but many
times for instance to be split for
different vehicle types and yeah some it
really depends on the model then how you
partition and split your data
Oh over here have you because he showed
you're working with the scikit-learn
have you looked at like distributed
machine learning are you using this like
the spark ml lip or the h2o for example
I'd say actually no go ahead
yeah it's an interesting question so we
we've also looked into its pact and Elsa
spa Comella list for the data products
I'm working if we haven't used it yet
but yeah it's I'm not sure if the
quality is really so good so there are
many so we talked to many people tried
out some things and we were not really
like you about the results we had and so
we thought okay we rather stick with a
scikit-learn and what we get there and
also with h2o so forth there all we ever
loved we actually using h2 almost all
the times because it's a very nice way
to distribute between like the Python
even our part and our a serving layer
which is Java so that was very
successful so far many really quick
follow up for that so how's that working
like the integration with like spark and
Joe actually I stood the question the
spark and h2o like how's it working not
technically how's it working but is it
working well I think it's very good
layer two like okay you can set it up
either on pison side you put it in spike
and then you'll learn your model and the
moment you have the data you can like
pretty much use all the h2o libraries
and then you can directly serve it from
there so we're using mojo files
mostly to ship it into a production
environment and then you take it from
there and serve it from the Java layer
it works and it works fast so that's
yeah we're actually just over there if
you come out you're probably concede us
at our booth Thanks
you